Sally Satel: Imagine the worst headache of your life,
multiply it by a thousand, you have it
every day. For some people, the only
medication that works are opioids.
Amy Monahan-Curtis: My name is Amy. I'm from Cincinnati Ohio.
One
day I was walking to class and I simply
stepped off the curb, came down on my knee
and my hands. And then a couple weeks
later, I had such intense screaming pain
down my arm. The doctor diagnosed me with
cervical dystonia. He started me on
regular Botox shots and then medications,
usually muscle relaxers, and then
sometimes pain medication.
Anne Fuqua: My name is Anne Fuqua
and I'm from Birmingham, Alabama.
When I was a child I was originally
diagnosed with mild cerebral palsy. They said, you know, it wouldn't get any worse, but
they didn't pick up on the fact that I
had dystonia and not CP at the time. This
was the point that I first started
taking quote-unquote "pain pills" and
it was not something that I wanted to do
at all but it helped. Back when I was
down on lower dose, well completely off
of the opioids, you know, doing something
like, you know, just standing up like that
would be almost impossible by myself. I
think what people don't understand is
pain medication is not something that
takes your pain away. It helps take off a
little edge so that you're just not
completely screaming.
Sally Satel: The problem is that
doctors are becoming increasingly
pressured to reduce prescribing for even
these chronic patients and they either
taper them off or they discontinue them.
They're told to find other doctors.
Amy Monahan-Curtis: I've already had one incident where a pharmacist would not fill my doctor's
prescription for my pain medication. I
went into withdrawal. I had a lot of
tremors and muscle aches and nausea, and
she refused to fill the prescription the
doctor filled. And this this is not uncommon at all.
Much of doctors' fear of prescribing
medications for people in chronic pain
can be traced to a guideline produced by
the CDC — Centers for Disease Control — in 2016.
Anne Fuqua: So many people I care about, you know,
have committed suicide and it's just
such a sad thing. I mean basically back
then I was doing anything possible to
try to find a doctor and trying to make
the medication I had last as long as it,
you know, as long as it could. But I had
pretty much decided that, you know, once
it runs out it runs out. And if I don't
get any, you know, don't get any fluids,
don't eat anything, don't drink anything,
you know, it would be over pretty quickly. I mean I
don't want to die I mean I just don't
want to live like that, though.
Amy Monahan-Curtis: I am scared every single day that the treatment that helps my condition will
be gone. That every time I have an
appointment will be the day that I'm
told I won't be helped anymore.